Mar fait la Parbelle entre vos deux
films dans dimanche 2
cinéma madame monsieur bonsoir voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce dimanche 2
décembre un épilogue heureux après la
disparition d'un enfant de 3 ans à
Saint-Laurent Dupont dans l'iser après
une nuit d'angoisse il a été retrouvé
sain et sauf le petit garçon a passé la
nuit dans la forêt il était à plus d'un
km de chez lui quelle victoire pour
Vladimir Poutine 109 millions
d'électeurs russes sétaient appelés aux
urnes pour élir leurs députés
l'opposition a dénoncé aujourd'hui de
nombreuses violations nous irons à
Moscou afin de découvrir les premières
estimations et analyser ses résultats
les Français et le travail le dimanche
la question revient au cœur des débats
après les propositions du président de
la République cette semaine volontariat
doublement de la rémunération qu'en
penseent les salariés c'est la question
économique du jour le sport et le
football avec le tirage au sort de
l'Euro 2008 et les retrouvailles entre
la France et l'Italie un groupe où il
faudra également affronter les Pays-Bas
et la Roumanie nous reviendrons aussi
sur le 4e titre de champion du monde des
rally de Sébastien lob et puis du cinéma
à la fin de ce journal avec notre invité
ce soir Charlotte ginsbourg qui incarne
la femme de Bob Dylan dans un film
étonnant qui retrace les vies du
chanteur
américain et commençons donc ce journal
ce soir par cette histoire qui après
avoir inquiété tout un village c'est
finalement bien é tout cela s'est
déroulé à Saint-Laurent du pont dans
l'iser après plus de 16 he de recherche
Matthéo âgé de 3 ans qui avait disparu a
donc été retrouvé saint et sauf durant
toutes ces heures des bénévoles et les
gendarmes ont tenté de retrouver sa
trace en pensant parfois au pire mais
l'enfant avait parcouru 1 km et s'était
réfugié dans les bois Denis Sébastien
Philippe
évec vivant et en bonne santé c'est un
père épuisé mais heureux qui nous montre
la photo de son FS Matthéo avait disparu
de la ferme familiale hier
après-midi un père qui n'a pas ménagé sa
peine toute la nuit il a sillonné les
alentours sur son tracteur équipé de
projecteurs et ce n'est qu'en milieu de
matinée que le petit garçon va être
retrouvé et rendu à ses parents c'est un
qui qui se l' bien pris dans les bras
et c'est pas grave il était
là il était là Mato quoi en tout cas ça
ça brasse les tripes ça fait mal et ça
fait c'est très dur
soulagement aussi pour la centaine de
secouristes et les nombreux habitants
qui se sont
mobilisésette de mais ce matin ils
étaient des dizaines de bénévoles à
venir en renfort pour les recherches et
c'est d'ailleurs l'un d'eux qui a
retrouvé l'enfant une grande joie pour
pour tout le monde pour les parents le
grand-père qui est avec nous qui faisait
les recherches avec nous pour la
population pour tout le monde retrou SAU
sans hypothermie sans rien du tout et
éorme c'est vraiment c'est la joie c'est
bien il est pleé 10 minutes court lapse
de temps pendant lequel Matthéo a
échappé à la vigilance de sa maman il a
marché et dormi dans ce bois 1000 m
seulement de sa maison par 2 degrés au
thermomètre ce sont ces pleurs au réveil
qui ont éveillé laattention plus ça
allit plus on se faisait de de soucis
néanmoins la nuit n'a pas été
extrêmement froide très humide certes du
brouillard mais les températures
n'étaient pas négatives il était
semble-t-il correctement équipé pour
passer une nuit ma fois sans trop de
problème le petit garçon a été conduit à
l'hôpital pour des examens de contrôle
vêtu cette nuit d'une d'un pantalon et
de botte il souffre simplement d'une
légère hypothermie au pied du mauvais
temps ce dimanche météoance a finalement
levé son alerte orange dans l'après-midi
la tempête annoncié était en fait un
gros coup de vent sur la façade ouest du
pays mais les rafales ont parfois
atteint plus de 100 kmh à calé ou encore
à westant faisons le point en image sur
cette journée avec Arnaud conte et
Tristan
lebz la mer démontée se fracasse contre
les rochers dans le Finistère les creux
sont parfois supérieurs à
m les rafales de vent à 110 km/h glacent
la peau des rares équilibristes a osé
mettre un pied dehors tire les rites
c'est très bon pour le teint voilà c'est
une une bonne
brumisation en raison de la tempête les
liaisons maritimes vers les îles de
Saint Molen et Ouessant sont suspendu
jusqu'à lundi plus de 200 retours vers
le continent étaient pourtant prévu cet
après-midi en Normandie la mer en furie
a attiré de nombreux bateaux au
premières loges sur les digues est
presque sous les vagues à Dieb cet
après-midi le jeu tendance consistait à
s'en prendre plein la figure pas très
prudent tout ça des sensations fortes
mais c'est marrant il faut vivre
dangereusement de toute façon si on
tombe on tombe du côté où c'est calme
voil on sait nagé d'autres plus
raisonnables préfèrent contempler de la
plage sans prendre de risque sur la côte
d'Opal les vent on soufflé à plus de 120
kmh en Rafal des images impressionnantes
mais les dégâts sont infimes des
panneaux publicitaires qui s'envolent
des fil électriques tombé sur la
chaussée mais rien de dramatique au
Havre et à Gonfreville lorcher de
quartiers ont subi le passage d'une mini
tornade très brève et très localisé une
soantaine d'arbres arraché et une
quinzaine de toitures endommagé cet
automobiliste a eu très chaud elle a
juste eu le temps de sortir de son
véhicule l'alerte est maintenant levée
mais les vents reste soutenu pour le
plus grand plaisir des amateurs de
sensation
extrême l'hommage aujourd'hui de
l'Espagne au jeunes memre de La Guardia
civile assassiné hier en France à breton
par des membres présumés de l' ta homage
solennel en présence du roi Juan Carlos
et du Premier ministre José Luis
sappatero les trois membres du mouvement
séparatiste basse n'ont toujours pas été
retrouvés ils sont en fuite depuis plus
de 24 heur maintenant où on est
l'enquête ce soir et dernier témoignage
sur cette affaire avec la jeune femme
qui avait été prise en otage hier David
bazier et Philippe dumaï Fanny til
l'exotage de le TA parmi les siens
samedi peu après avoir tiré sur les
gardes civils le commando s'est emparé
de sa voiture il roule vite fanny est
enfermé dans le coffre le coffre s'est
ouvert donc j'ai hurlé j'ai crié au
secours il y avait des gens trois
personnes au bord de la route j'aurais
pu sauter mais c'est vrai que ça roulait
enfin il roulait vraiment très très vite
tout en roulant la femme du commando l'a
fait glisser à l'arrière lui couvre les
yeux les hommes à bord avaent l'air
d'être assez énervés et elle elle a eu
des propos quand même assez rassurant
même si c'était des mots c'était quand
même c'était quand même des des paroles
rassurante quoi et elle me tenait la
main 2hur après enfin elle est libérée
attachée à un arbre moi j'avais surtout
peur que décide de me
supprimer donc voilà j'ai eu surtout de
grandes pensées pour ma famille pour mes
petits pour mon mari Fanny se détachera
rejoindra les gendarmes le plan Épervier
a été levé le commando est toujours en
fuite certainement à l'abri dans l'une
des multiples caches de le Tha en France
c'était là o où le ce client de la
cafétéria de Ceton nous montre comment
garde civil et commando ETA étaient
assis par hasard presque côte à côte les
policiers parlaient fort il par pas pas
repéré à la sortie l'officier Raoul
sinteno est tué à bout portant à
l'hôpital de Bayonne son collègue est
dans un état de mort cérébrale les
habitants de cabreton se disent choqués
jusqu'à maintenant il y avait jamais eu
le sversé
c'était on savait que des gens de l'ta
venaent ici enfin dans dans le sud-ouest
se mettre à l'abri cacher des armes ou
se mais jamais jamais il nétait venu à à
de telles extrémités 300 g de substances
explosives ont été retrouvé dans le
véhicule de le TA mais on ignore
toujours pourquoi le commando a décidé
de tirer sur les gardes civiles François
Fillon réunissé ce soir à Matignon pas
moins de 10 ministres au cœur des
discussions le pouvoir d'achat
l'objectif était de proposer des mesures
suite aux propositions faites par
Nicolas Sarkozi cette semaine et les
premières décisions viennent de tomber
on écoute François Fillon j'ai décidé
que dans les tous prochains jours serait
soumis au Parlement un texte permettant
le rachat des heures de RTT et des
comptes
épargnant le déblocage de la
participation et la mise en place d'une
prime de 1000 € dans les entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés qui n'ont pas
vocation à mettre en œuvre le système de
la participation j'ai demandé à ERC vert
d'engager immédiatement dès la semaine
prochaine la concertation avec les
organisations syndicale de la fonction
publique euh pour l'application des
mesures spécifiques à la fonction
publique sur les heures supplémentaires
et sur les rachats de RTT autre
proposition faite par Nicolas Sarkozi
cette semaine celle du travail le
dimanche le chef de l'État souhaite que
cela soit négocié dans les entreprise
sur la base du volontariat le salaire du
dimanche étant doublement payé qu'en
penseent les salariés prenons ce soir un
exemple celui d'une entreprise qui
réalise 25 % de son chiffre d'affaires
le dimanche cyrilza Valérie Luca Karine
oui tu as tu as pu récupérer des
personnes pour c'est un dimanche comme
un autre un dimanche d'affluence on
répartit les effectifs car aujourd'hui
dans ce magasin de la région parisienne
8000 clients vont passer en caisse 250
employés sont mobilisés la possibilité
de travailler le dimanche comme le
propose Nicolas Sarkozi ici ça ne choque
pas les salariés je travaille depuis 18
ans un weekend sur de donc oui je ne
vois que des
avantages vous feriez la même chose
travailler le dimanche euh je le feraiis
oui si j'avais besoin de mieux gagner ma
vie oui mais je voudrais que ce soit un
choix pas qu'on me l'impose et que je
puisse choisir que ce soit un milange de
temps en temps et que ce soit pas
systématique en fait c'est sur la base
du volontariat voilà volontaire est bien
payé cette journée rémunérée à 225 %
plus que la proposition présidentielle
résultat pour de dimanches travaillés
par mois 300 € en plus sur la feuille de
paix et pas seulement et moi j'adore
travailler le dimanche pour une simple
raison saavir une journée de repos en
semaine hors la foule c'est génial des
ff di
pour pas dans toutes
lesreis pour l'heure cette mesure ne
concerne que les enseignes situées dans
des zones bien spécifiques Nicolas
Sarkozi souhaite que le débat s'ouvre
pour qu'entrepris et salariés puissent
il le veulent travailler le dimanche la
politique toujours François Baayou est
donc devenu le premier président du
Mouvement Démocrate élection avec 96 %
des votants le modem s militant était
réuni en congrès fondateur à Villepinte
en scè saintemis François baayrou qui
malgré les défections de certains depuis
quelques temps a souhaité rassurer ses
troupes on l'écoute aujourd'hui j'eris
je ne me sens pas seul quand j'ai autour
de moi les femmes et les hommes qui sont
à cette tribune je ne me sent pas
seul eux ne sont pas là parce que ils
penseraient trouver ici un avantage
d'ambition ils sont là parce qu'ils
croient à ce que nous faisons et qu'ils
ont la certitude que la société
française attend de cette équipe qu'elle
lui propose un chemin nouveau à
l'étranger avant de retrouver à notre
correspondant afin de faire le point sur
les premiers résultats de ces élections
législatives voyons comment le vote des
109 millions d'électeurs s'est déroulé
aujourd'hui l'enjeu pour Vladimir
Poutine était de connaître l'ampleur de
sa victoire une chose est sûre
l'opposition a très vite dénoncé tout au
long de la journée de nombreuses
violations lors du scrutin sur place
Laurent Boussier Xavier luiset c'est une
des nombreuses spécificité du vote en
Russie pratiquement pas de
confidentialité et le choix de chacun
exposé au scrutateurs au moment de
glisser son bulletin dans l'URE pour
certains évidemment ça n'est pas un
problème devant des dizaines de caméras
Vladimir Poutine a voté ostensiblement
pour son parti Russie
uni je suis sûr que l'électeur a
déterminé ses préférences il faut
maintenant venir et voter pour le parti
dont le programme vous semble
convainquant sûr de sa victoire le
président russe est ensuite allé
déjeuner avec son épouse dans un petit
restaurant de quartier affluence aussi
autour de parov libéré jeudi après avoir
passé 5 jours en prison l'opposant le
plus connu à l'étranger a barré d'une
grande croix son bulletin pour le rendre
nul parce que vous ne pouvez pas appeler
cela des élections ou alors ce sont des
élections mais sans choix pour les
électeurs de l'Extrême Orient russe à
l'enclave de caliningrade en Europe sur
11 fuseux horaires c'est plus de 109
millions d'électeurs qui étent appelés
aux ures l'opposition dénonce des
irrégularités comme la présence
aujourd'hui encore dans Mosou de ces
drapeau du parti du président qui aurait
dû être retiré depuis plus de 48
he on dit que tout est décidé d'avance
mais moi j'espère toujours que ma voix
servira à quelque
chose première satisfaction pour
Vladimir Poutine ce soir même si des
fraudes semblent évidentes le taux de
participation est proche de 60 % et on
retrouve à Moscou Laurent Boussier
bonsoir Laurent alors quels sont les
premiers résultats ce soir
comme prévu le parti Russie Unie de
Vladimir Poutine arrive très largement
en tête plus de
62,8 % des voix un vote classique en
Russie un vote de légitimé de de
légitimation 2uxème arrivée aussi 2è
comme prévu également le Parti
communiste avec 11,8 % des voix des
communistes pas contents du tout ils
dénoncent des fraudes massives deses des
fautes extraordinaires d'yle et ils ont
décidé de porter plainte devant la Cour
suprême de Russie alors autre question
que va faire de cette victoire en forme
de référendum Vladimir Poutine bah plus
qu'un référendum c'est presque un
plébiscite pour Vladimir Poutine si
c'estes ses résultats se confirment
alors effectivement c'est la question
que se pose ce soir à la fois la grande
majorité des Russes et surtout les
hommes d'affaires les businessman qui
veulent absolument eux que Vladimir
Poutine reste au pouvoir que va-t-il
faire pour garder le pouvoir pour rester
pour diriger toujours le pays après les
présidentielles du mois de mars pour
l'instant c'est une question mais il n'y
a pas de réponse merci Laurent et
apparemment il fait très très froid
Nicolas Sarkozi se rendra demain en
Algérie pour une visite d'État de 3
jours le président de la République qui
souhaite se tourner vers l'avenir
réconcilier les mémoires plusieurs
accords économiques sont également en vu
et il faut savoir que deux nombreux
Français d'origine algérienne des
Français dit de la 4e génération ont
fait le choix de travailler sur le sol
algérien et cela à l'heure de la
mondialisation voici pourquoi c'est le
grand format de ce soir reportage
samasoula
quand il marche dans les rues d'Alger
Mourad mafouf français d'origine
algérienne ne croisent que des jeunes
qui rêvent de partir en France lui a
pourtant choisi de traverser la
Méditerranée dans l'autre sens il
s'installe au pays de ses parents je me
sentais pas trop mal en France mais
disons que cette j'avais pas envie de
développer cette paranoïa qui consiste à
à tout mettre sur le dos du
racisme pour peu qu'
parle mal à Paris le jeune homme de 32
ans éta gérant d'une société de
téléphonie
mobileg il CR propr reprise
d'agroalimentaire pour tous mour Maou n
Françis algérien il est le patron
yés il a d les former sa démarche de
retour au RAC il la qualifie de
citoyenne j'aurais pu monter exactement
la même structure en France avec plus de
facilité connaissant les lourdeurs
administratives algériennes c'est c'est
évident mais j'ai choisis quand même
d'investir dans mon pays d'origine dans
une Algérie au potentiel économique
inconsidérable les franco-algériens ont
un profil particulièrement recherché le
plus grand groupe industriel algérien en
a recruté 10 et derniers
mois ils ont reçu une bonne formation et
dans certaines spécialités ils ont aussi
une certaine expérience une opportunité
de carrière inespérée pour cette ind
décrotable parisien supporter du PSG il
parle à peine l'arabe mais c'est en
Algérie que ce bac + 5 a fini par
trouver un emploi j'ai souffert dans le
sens où euh où je trouvais pas mon
premier emploi quoi tout simplement et
au fur et à mesure qu'on avançait dans
le dans les mois euh euh moi je vois que
toute ma promotion est quasiment tous
casé sauf euh
et on est j'étais le seul à pas toujours
6 mois après à N pas trouvé un
emploi dans quelques jours Mourad mafouf
le chef d'entreprise sera rejoint à
Alger par sa femme et son
bébé pour moi doravant la France ce sera
uniquement pour aller skier dans les
Alpes pour aller faire du shopping à
Paris un regroupement familial à
l'envers le phénomène est encore récent
mais la tendance s'accélère de plus en
plus de Français d'origine algérienne
sont tentés d'exploiter leur double
culture pour investir dans l'immense
marché
algérien en France la campagne des
Restos du cœur s'ouvre demain des
millions de repas seront cette année
encore servis au plus démunis au-delà de
l'aide humanitaire alimentaire
l'association cré par Coluche propose
également de loger des personnes en
difficulté un toit un hébergement offert
le temps de reprendre pied reportage
dans la Vienne Anne gupé et Fabien
tormous bonjour bonjour depuis un an les
deux femmes se voient chaque semaine ça
va depuis ce jour où Véronique a été
hébergée en urgence par les toit du cœur
expulsé de chez elle avec ses trois
enfants parce qu'elle ne pouvait plus
payer son loyer pourtant cette aide
soignante gagne 1500 € par mois mais
avec les dettes impossible de se reloger
il y a quelques années je pense que
c'est une situation que j'aurais pu
vivre normalement mais
aujourd'huiah le le le la vie est
tellement chère que on bascule très vite
quoi et sans les toit du cœur vous ariez
fait ben je pense que je dormirai dans
ma voiture là depuis un an Nicole
bénévole des toits du cœur s'occupe de
tout et d'abord du confort des huit
appartements meublés avec les moyens du
bord ils sont déjà dans une situation
tellement tellement grave et désespéré
que le fait les appartements meublés
même si c'est pas un un ameublement qui
nous
convient pour eux c'est quand même un
plus c'est l'association locataire des
logements qui les loy et les factures
d'électricité mais pour un temps
seulement l'objectif est d'aider les
résidents à trouver un autre appartement
et pour votre CDI début janvier ah ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle le CDI va vous
aider dans les les dossier de relogement
ça c'est vraiment une bonne
nouvelle les personnes que l'on héberge
font partie de notre vie et nous on doit
faire partie de laaleure je pense à un
moment au passage au toit du cœur on
fait partie de leur vie
un engagement quotidien pour Nicole et
tous les bénévoles les toit du cœur ont
hébergé l'an dernier en France plus d'un
millier de
personnes santé avec cette prouesse
médicale qui date d'il y a 40 ans déjà
le 3 décembre 1967 un chirurgien le
professeur Christian Barnard entré dans
l'histoire il réalisait ce jour-là la
première greffe de cœur un événement qui
allait changer la vie de milliers de
personnes José blanclapierre et Daniel
lvy un travail une vie sentiment bref un
peu monsieur tout le monde sauf que
Patrick Borel 45 ans vit avec le cœur
d'un autre et pas depuis hier depuis 25
ans toute votre vie vous sentez votre
cœur maintenant c'est mon cœur à moi
j'ai plus longtemps que l'ancien mais
vous le sentez vous le sentez vivre il
bouge c'est il y a des pulsations donc
c'est quand même humainement une
expérience une expérience humaine
transplanter un cœur humain le tabou est
bravé pour la première fois il y a 40
ans en Afrique du Sud cap c'est un
exploit sans précédent que vient de
réaliser l'équipe du professeur Barnard
en greffant le cœur d'une jeune femme et
même si le patient âgé de 56 ans
succombe après 18 jours techniquement ça
marche le professeur Barnard entre dans
l'histoire quand j'ai quitté l'hôpital
ce matinl il n'y avait ni micro ni
caméra télévision on nait pas encore
annoncé l'opération et c'est plus tard
qu'on s'est rendu compte de l'importance
de l'événement
Cabrol devit décrire en Europe le
professeur Cabrol est le premier
Français à se lancer dans l'aventure en
avril 68 le malade est en condition
défor un geste chirurgical qui même
après l'avoir pratiqué des centaines de
fois depuis l' Meux toujours un cœur
normal c'est pas plus gros que ça c'est
comme de deain et je me dis mais jamais
ça va
marcher il est trop petit et quand on a
eu tout fini la greffe et qu'on on a
voulu le faire repartir voà il y a un
moment d'émotion et puis hop il est
reparti top top top top alors je dis pas
qu'on a eu des
les c'était tout juste à l'époque
l'exception c'est lui Emmanuel Vitria ce
Marseillais qui a survécu 20 ans à une
greffe car la plupart rejette ce corps
étranger et seule la découverte en 1980
d'un médicament antirejet a permis de
rallonger considérablement la durée de
vie des patients avec avec un nouvel
espoir aujourd'hui celui des cœurs
artificiels ça solutionne pas tous les
cœurs mais ça réduit fortement le manque
de donneur que l'on a toujours de façon
cruciale des donneur de plus en plus
rare en particulier pour les enfants et
la petite Jeanne greffée l'année
dernière à 4 mois revient de
loin aujourd'hui 80 % des greffes du
cœur sont une réussite et la moitié des
patients survivent au-delà de 12
années la page sport de ce dimanche soir
avec un tirage au sort très attendu
aujourd'hui celui de l'Euro 2008 de
football et les Bleus devront affronter
l'Italie comment on se retrouve les
Pays-Bas et la Roumanie un groupe
difficile mais finalement de belles
affiches en perspective il faut savoir
que seul les deux premiers de ce groupe
accéderont au quart de finale les forces
en présence manuel
tisier comme un frisson dans la
salle et un coup de froid pour le
sélectionneur les retrouvailles avec
l'Italie de Roberto Donadoni n'ont pas
fait rire Raymond domenek depuis la
finale de l'Euro 2000 et le but
victorieux de tr3g l'Italie et la France
sont en compte à la détresse des
Italiens vaincu a succédé la revanche de
Berlin et le retour triomphal de
Canavaro en juillet 2006 les Bleus ne
pouvaient pas affronter plus dangereux
que les champions du monde
Rimon il aurait peut-être souhaité autre
chose mais il aura pas grand mal à
motiver ses troupes c'est déjà une bonne
chose car dans ce groupe C le plus
relevé du tournoi il faudra aussi
compter avec un ancien champion d'Europe
Marco vanbasten buteur en finale de
l'Euro 88 est aujourd'hui sélectionneur
des Pays-Bas l'un des plus beaux
football du
continent c'est un groupe qui est qui
est difficile mais on y on y est préparé
et on a pour objectif de remporter C EUR
donc peu importe qui qui on a dans notre
groupe il faudra il faudra passer et les
vaincre pendant les éliminatoires les
Pays-Bas ont fini derrière la Roumanie
4e Laron de ce groupe C les Roumains et
leurs maillots jaunes seront les
premiers adversaires des Bleus le 9 juin
à zuurric la France restera en
suissealémanique pour ce premier tour à
Bern le 13 juin puis retour à Zuc pour
conclure pour une petite finale le 17
contre l'Italie et faisons le point sur
les autres groupes de la compétition le
match d'ouverture opposera la Suisse à
la République tchèque dans ce groupe on
retrouvera le Portugal et la Turquie
l'autrichelle lancera son tournoi face à
la Croatie puis l'Allemagne et la
Pologne seront ses adversaires enfin la
Grèce entamera la défense de son titre
contre la Suède dans ce groupe D on
retrouve également la Russie l'Espagne
rendez-vous donc le 7 juin dans le reste
de l'actualité Sport de ce weekend un
ballon d'or brésilien le PSG en crise la
coupe DESV américaines et Sébastien lob
champion du monde à nouveau nathanel de
rinxin c'est presque une tradition
depuis 4 ans Sébastien lob remporte le
titre mondial des pilotes cet après-midi
sur les routes boueuses du pays de Gal
le Français a assuré la r grandbretagne
sastiob daniena sonilote dev au Clement
le Finlandais Marcus grolm de 4 point au
terme d'une saison qui a RAR ét aussi
disputé en r une erreur même de quelques
centimètres peut avoir des conséquences
terribl weekend Andreas norvégien percut
un gros caillou à pleine vitesse
l'accident est
spectaculaire mais l'équipage en sort
secou
c'est le seul trophée qui manquait à son
palmarès il a tout juste 25 ans pourtant
ce matin caca est allé chercher le
ballon d'or qui récompense le meilleur
footballeur de l'année le PSG aussi a un
joueur brésilien dans son effectif
malheureusement hier il n'a pas été très
brillant Tiara a glissé sur le ballon
doré du match une maladresse technique
qui profite à Nicolas florentin le cané
Paris s'incline 1 à 0 et reste 18e au
classement la situation devient de plus
en plus compliquée pour pour l'équipe de
Paul
Leen voilà 12 ans que les États-Unis
n'avaient pas remporté la coupe des vis
cette nuit les frère Bryan en double ont
facilement dominé Andreev et David Enko
les Américains battent les Russes 3-0
c'est la 32e coupe DESV remporté par les
États-Unis parlons environnement
maintenant avec cette décision
symbolique à la veille de l'ouverture de
la Conférence sur le climat à Bali
l'Indonésie a ainsi lancé une vaste
campagne objectif plter 10 millions
d'arbres il faut savoir que le pays est
fortement touché par la déforestation et
cette question sera justement l'un des
enjeux de ce sommet voyons pourquoi avec
Agnès Monteux et Bruno
Girodon plus de 60000 feux l'année
dernière rien qu'en Indonésie et
derrière cette jungle millénaire qui
part en fumée c'est aussi un immense
réservoir de carbone qui se vide dans
l'atmosphère voilà comment l'Indonésie
est aujourd'hui devenu le trè plus gros
ém
eff ser derrière lesats-unis et la
Chine uniquement à cause de sa
déforestation la plus rapide au monde
ici les forêts sont des tourbières
marécageuses à très forte concentration
de CO2 des militants écologistes s'y
sont installés pour sauver ce qu'il en
reste leur but perturber l'écoulement de
ces canaux construits par les
exploitants en pleine forêt pour évacuer
l'humidité les expits vont avant ces
forêts c'estàd sortir l'eau des forêts
pour pour assécher et ensuite une fois
que le le niveau d'eau a diminué on va
défricher et mettre le feu sur ces
forêts pour planter des palmiers à huile
par la suite des milliards de palmiers à
perte de vue dont les fruits serviront
pour une huile bon marché ou des
biocarburants des plantations qui
n'absorbent pas autant de carbone que
les
forêts ce problème de déforestation se
retrouve partout dans le monde Indonésie
Brésil pour cultiver du soja ou
République démocratique du Congo ces
vieilles forêts ont accumulé dans leurs
arbres et leurs sols une fois et demi
plus de carbone que dans l'atmosphère
leur disparition émett aujourd'hui 1/5e
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
dans le monde plus que les transports
alors tous les pays riches sont
aujourd'hui d'accord il faut payer les
pays forestiers pour ne plus
déboiser la Banque mondiale estime qu'il
faudrait mettre jusqu'à 100 milliards de
dollars pour arrêter la déforestation je
pense pas qu'on pourra arrêter la
déforestation je pense qu'on pourra
réduire le niveau de déforestation cela
coûtera quelques milliards ça coûtera
quelques milliards de dollars par an à
qui donner cet argent les États les
agriculteurs les exploitants et comment
surveiller autant de discussions
difficiles qui se dérouleront à la
conférence de Bali pour sauver les
derniers poumons de la planète la page
cinéma de ce dimanche avec dans un
instant notre invité Charlotte ginsbourg
qui est à laffiche de am nozer film
consacré au visage multiple de Bob Dylan
film esthétique où six acteurs dont une
actrice k blanch incarne l'icône pop
américaine marieo é
de dans son Minesota natal le jeune
Rober Zimerman aim la poésie le folk
wood Elis Presley un écletisme qui
annoncit déjà l'ampleur de celui qui
deviendrait Bob Dylan figure
emblématique des années 60 et véritable
mut
si acteurs dont une actrice incarne ici
dyan à différentes époques de sa vie
tour à tour poète sous l'inluence de
contestataire de la marche Washington
prophète converti au christianisme dans
les années
70 le réalisateur a trouvé une façon
originale de concentrer les multiples
facettes de
l'icône que son public le suiva dans une
direction il l'abandonna pour passer à
autre
choseéta
de protéger créativité sa
fraîcheur interprété par blanch le Dylan
androgine est controversé de 1966
choquant ses F en opérant un virage vers
le RO une métamorphose
surprenante quand on s'invente un
personnage il faut que ce soit raccord
avec sa silhouette qui sort de ma bouche
et celle d'un homme chanté par quelqu'un
d'autre même si les idées sont de Dylan
au final le personnage que j'ai créé
donne cet étrange
hybride quant à la vie sentimentale du
chanteur une seule femme incarnée par
Charlotte gbour résume tout c que Dylan
a aimé roto
SAR cette déclinaison sur Bob dyoquer
des débats par les fans pour les autres
voilà un film de cinéaste inventif et
brillant et si Bob Dylan a donné sa
bénédiction au réalisateur pour le
tourné il n'a toujours pas vu le
film et avec nous celle qui incarne dans
ce film la femme de Bob Dylan on est
très heureux de la retrouver bonsoir
Charlot gansbourg merci d'être avec nous
beaucoup de gens ont pensé à vous au
mois de septembre lors de votre
hémorragie cérébrale la première
question c'est comment allez-vous je
vais très bien oui j'ai pas eu enfin B
je v pas revenir dessus mais hémorragie
cérébrale ça fait un peu peur j'ai eu
quelque chose de très grave
mais mes proches ont eu très peur moi
aussi j'ai eu très peur mais ça y est je
su je suis tirée d'affire tout va bien
alors parl cinéma maintenant avec ce
film c'est en fait je je joue pas c'est
Julien mour qui joue John
Baez moi je joue plutôt le un mélange
entre sus Rotolo et Sarah qui a été sa
vraie femme alors qui vous a initié à à
Bob Dylan votre père mon père m'a initié
en me disant d'acheter l day ce qui
était un de ses titres préférés
j'imagine donc c'est par ce biais là que
je l'ai connu avec une compilation et
puis c'est vrai qu'il m'a jamais quitté
jusque jusqu'à aujourd'hui oui beaucoup
vous auriez pu être la la femme d'un
compositeur comme
ça je je me suis pas posé la question le
réalisateur Tod ha il vous voulait
absolument je crois c'est ce qu'on m'a
dit c'est ce que lui m'a dit aujourd'hui
je dé avec lui c'est ce qu' m'a redit
oui j'ai du mal à le croire mais enfin
si je veux je veux bien le croire j'ai
l'impression que
il il a il a le regard que je porte sur
l'Amérique c'est ses yeux à lui donc
voilà il s'est mis dans les dans dans le
personnage féminin que j'incarne
peut-être et bon alors je sais pas
pourquoi il m'a voulu euh c'est vrai que
moi je quand j'ai reçu ce scénario
venant de lui c'était moi qui étais une
grande fan de son travail j'ai j'adore
safe j'ai adoré Loin du paradis donc
c'était un M en scène vraiment comment
on va qualifier ce film flamboyant
esthétique très original c'est un rythme
qui est original c'est c'est il faut
c'est un voyage sur Dylan on n pas
besoin de d'y connaître grand-chose sur
et moi-même j'y connaissais pas
grand-chose quand j'ai lu le scénario
sur sa vie il a ça garde beaucoup de
mystères et c'était important il y a
rien de plus inventif que de faire un
film sur les différentes facettes d'un
artiste je pense que ça peut se ça peut
se faire sur plein d'artistes différents
mais en l'occurrence Dylan c'est vrai
que justement pour cette part de mystère
de mensonge de voilà c'était très
intéressant de le voir comme ça alors
vous êtes une artiste complète votre
album a été un succès cette année est-ce
que enfin vous avez été contente de vous
parce qu'il paraît que vous êtes très
difficile avec vous très dur euh
contente de moi quoi comme bilan de
l'année oui avec l'album qui est ouais
j'étais contente j'étais contente pas du
pas du résultat mais de l'accueil de du
succès euh des films voilà j'espère que
je touche du bois il y en a là ouis ça
continue un mot d'un projet qui vous
tient je crois particulièrement à cœur
le musée Serge ginzebau il va exist un
jour ça fait plusieurs années que les en
parlé euh là vraiment j'ai l'impression
que ça prend forme parce que Jean Nouvel
à à dessiner le projet euh que on est
prêt à aller voir des mescenes pour pour
demander des fonds euh et que le projet
vraiment euh est viable enfin voilà
c'est ça et derait TR de Verneuil à
Paris oui c'est important c'est ce
serait le le seul musée sur un sur un
artiste aussi important que mon père à
Saint-Germain Despré voilà ça ça a
beaucoup de sens et je pense que ça ça
vaut ça vaut le coup ouais ça vaut le
coup en tout cas merci Charlot ginsbourg
on vousetroura donc à laaffiche ce
mercredi de am noodzer film qui revient
donc sur la vie de de Bob Dylan et
désormais chaque dimanche nous ferons le
point sur le box office des sorties
cinéma de la semaine en tête depuis
mercredi il était une fois des studios
Disney Les Femmes de ses rêves avec Ben
Steeler La nuit nous appartient avec
jockin Phoenix enfin mike Blueberry
Knights le très beau film de wankw
information fournie par nos confrères
d'écran total et avant de refermer ce
journal l'image du jour c'est celle du
coup de vent qui a touché la façade
ouest du pays la Basse Normandie le
nordp decalais les Côtes d'Armor mais
également la somme on connu des vents
violents aujourd'hui on a relevé des
rafales à 118 kmh au Cap grinet mais
l'alerte orange a été levé en fin de
journée prudence tout de même ce soir
sur le
littoral voilà pour l'actualité de ce
dimanche merci de nous avoir suivi dans
un instant la météo isabelle Martinet
20h50 du cinéma avec l'échange un film
avec Meg Ryan et Rossell CRW vous
retrouverez des demain pour
l'information éise Lucé à 13h et
Françoise Laborde à 20h à vendredi belle
semaine à
vous info en continue c'est aussi sur
France
2.fr votre soirée